[Music]
all right with that like this long by
the way the Seattle region they didn't
talk on the fire
[Music]
Pass pass can you guys hear me
excellent okay for the last I don't know
10 15 years or so part of what I've been
responsible for is building out model
development platforms and I've been
doing this on a very very large scale
not like Google big or Facebook big but
just a shade below that the most recent
generation of model platforms I built
has been based on our and it is by far
the best model development and platform
I've worked with it's awesome it's super
fast and it's got all the benefits of
working with our open source and a big
part of why that works so well why it's
so fast is data table so as Jared
pointed out a few months back a member
of our community JD long presented on
deep flier
very cool talk very compelling little
controversial who knew that the
assignment operator can work left to
right that night what I was thinking is
it would be really cool to take be
inspired by what JD presented but look
at it through a data table Lance sent
Jared a message and JD a message they
were both pretty jazzed so here we are
so in addition to being inspired by JD's
format we're also using some of his puns
so
life in the fast lane awesome song by
joe walsh and the eagles an alternate
title didn't quite wanna didn't think it
would come across the way i might want
it to in an email but okay
where are we going today first we'll
talk about why should we use or why
should we consider using data table
we'll get into some of the key benefits
some of the design philosophies that
matt dole the creator of this package
put into it because I think that flavor
of why data table is the way it is helps
at least it helped me come through the
learning curve and maybe help you get
your heads wrapped around it then we'll
shift gears we'll go into the syntax
we'll go into some of the breadth and
depth of what data table can offer after
that we'll start looking at some real
world examples some cool things I think
functions I've layered on top of data
table real world code snippets that
highlight and hopefully leave you with
the impression of what data table looks
like in a real world environment and why
it might be a compelling package to use
then we'll dive into something
unexpected that's very very much related
to data table and last we'll talk about
some cool next steps that some they were
all related to data summer cañedo
connected with data table some not so
much but I think they're fun a little
bit about me think of me please as part
management consultant part data
scientists part technologist I started
my career as a developer trained as a
electrical engineer brought to market
commercial software with millions of
lines of code
very often found myself building the
ecosystems that models need to thrive
bill contained hundreds of models across
the customer lifecycle
mostly in finance insurance and medical
technology and yeah that's Oh a guest
lecturer at Columbia and NYU on the
topics of computer vision data and data
analytics I'm with a company called the
Teva here's how you can reach me it's
bill C gold and all these platforms and
tonight's this presentation will be
available here I'm guessing Jared we'll
get it out to you too TV is hiring by
the way we're looking for two data
scientists who are familiar with the
open source tools are Python three to
five years of experience some very cool
work part data science part consulting
if you have FinTech experience I'd be a
big big plus that's of interest just see
me out to here please so data table
quick show of hands how many of you
touched data table on a regular basis
daily weekly so data table first came
out in 2006 it was brought out by a
gentleman by the name of Matt dole and
he was looking to create a super-fast
package that addressed some of the
shortcomings he perceived with the
standard data frame and as of today it's
got a ton of traction and it's one of
the most followed tags and packages on
stackoverflow
why should we consider learning or
embracing data table there's really in
my mind three compelling reasons one is
it's crazy fast I mean really really
fast I work with ten years of big data
to do all sorts of compliance Basile see
car modeling I could take ten years of
account history and pivot it sort of
kind of the way you would have very
small except Excel spreadsheet and for
me the big benefit of that you know one
metric says if you as a data scientist
or suspending half of your time looking
for new patterns looking for new
insights and half of your time managing
data that's a pretty good balance from
what I've seen more than not spend more
time in the data management bucket and
for me data table has dramatically
enabled me to focus on finding new
insights trying new methods because the
speed of data management is just not a
constraint to me second reason is it's
concise there's two sides of concise
there's before the learning curve and
after the learning curve and each each
tells a very different story
hopefully in today's presentation will
help you come through and compress that
learning curve for data table we'll talk
about both sides but we'll spend a good
amount of time talking about what now
Matt Dole designed and why to me it's a
compelling design and lastly data table
integrates really really well with our
and all the rich functions and packages
you can tap this means that we're going
to touch on tonight
best is a relative thing as data
scientists hopefully we aspire to to
quantify things but but that's
skateboards looking free pretty good to
that turtle objectively data tables fast
some of you have may seen this these are
benchmarks put out by the data table
team they've been refreshed recently
within the last couple of months what
we're seeing here are five different
tests top to bottom the top is geared
towards it starts with a billion rows
nine columns 50 gigs of data that's
pretty big
the top has fewer groups each group with
more data the bottom has more groups
smaller data and what the one I'd like
you to take away is data table at the
top and glue is shorter is smaller than
the rest and shorter on these graphs on
these these bar charts is good so it is
substantially faster than then deep liar
and it's pretty competitive inspark is
pretty damn good platform and data table
is very very competitive with with spark
and these are all publicly available
then what the data table team did was
they took those benchmark numbers and
extrapolated them onto the economics of
hosting so what they're saying is it's
really cheaper from a hosting hardware
perspective to use data table
what data table difference one of the
big reasons is data table leverages
in-memory data processing heart the cost
of hardware's come down dramatically and
what data table does is it takes
advantage of all the memory that's
available to it and that's a big
paradigm shift memories fast it's less
taxing on your computer it really is a
huge driver of performance who here is
familiar with the concept by reference
versus by value many of you essentially
what the benefit of by reference is is
that data table can manipulate read and
write update data in place whereas data
frame needs to make a copy of that data
do what it's doing and then make another
copy to put it back great efficiencies
at times with F read F write data table
will use some parallel processing
methods and techniques algorithms are
apparently has some very very efficient
internal structures that that data data
table uses and leverages there's really
efficient sorting we'll go through that
in the presentation and a lot of those
methods that Matt Dolan team have used
are now finding their way back into base
are and also along those lines set key
is a very efficient way to structure
your data sort it first and then point
algorithms at your data that are highly
efficient because they know the data is
sorted we'll see that too as we go
through this all right let's shift gears
to concise we want to make favorite
comic strips Calvin and Hobbes
so this is Calvin's view of concise his
book report is crazy concise and he's a
concise writer all right
let's quantify a bit what concise means
here suppose our task is to look at
empty cars and do a little bit of
filtering and some aggregations okay
the data set as we find it in our has 32
rows but we're going to aggregate this
by cylinder and doing a bit of filtering
here's a bit of sequel code it would
take to create that aggregation what
we're saying here is that a large
quantity of the sequel code is
repetitive and the way I'd like you to
think about this is repetitive not from
an individual transaction but if we're
building a capability something that
solves a business problem for pricing
for market optimization we're gonna have
lots of this code that we have to create
debug and navigate through and if we
inherit something get our heads wrapped
around so so here what we're looking at
is 65 characters roughly half of that is
repetitive similar code for data frame
has about 90 characters of which 40 are
repetitive and we can see here that the
data frame code is function centric you
start with your function and you pass in
each parameter and that's important
because each parameter doesn't
necessarily know what the other
parameter contains why is that important
because you have to explicitly enumerate
to each parameter what your population
is that you're passing in data table on
the other hand is data centric so we
start with the data and everything flows
from there
it has three really concise parameters
that we're gonna talk about in depth and
breadth they're 27 characters were
repetitive it's data centric so in total
if we look at the broader set of sequel
and data table functions six repetitive
characters for data table 34 for sequel
and that's a count of repetitive
characters there's two contexts I'd like
you to think this about these are both
real-world contexts I used to be on top
of a pricing analytics group for a big
bank for their auto financing group and
I inherited a pricing engine it was
crazy complicated there's probably ten
models that went into pricing this is
the system that when you submit the
application to an auto dealer returns a
price six percent eight percent four
percent whatever it had to pull from six
different platforms and it was all
written in seal all when I printed out
the code it was probably somewhere in
the order of EDPs of a code it was
massive it took me months to get my head
wrapped around that so if we think of
this on offense six to one let's cut it
in half let's say three to one it would
take let's say a hundred pages of code
and bring that down to thirty same
function same functionality so to me
there's a ton of value in that concise
code I think it's quicker to develop
it's quicker to debug and you're much
much more agile in maintaining it over
time
all right that's the other side of
concise does anyone know what movie this
is from shiny that's right
that's right okay but I do want to be
cognizant of the other side of concise
concise is great and can you deliver
great code but if you're just starting
that learning curve concise and lots of
shortcuts symbols can increase your
learning curve so I do want to
acknowledge that and a big part of what
I was thinking about while pulling this
together is how does shorten that
learning curve
all right shifting gears to integrate it
any our function from any our package
can be used in Deer table queries that's
amazing there's so many rich packages
and functions already written and
available to us and we're gonna see that
a lot as we go through some of the code
samples okay
let's shift gears over to syntax and to
me this was one of the harder things as
I came through the learning curve
honestly I'm not a trained statistician
I learned this on the job so what is I
what is J what is bi and say there's
there's a weight think about that I
think that might make it easier for you
to get your head wrapped around each of
those functions and concepts available
to us and data table are available to us
in sequel first we're starting out with
our data table name that's analogous to
our our floor clause and select the I
first parameter is all about filtering
equivalent to our where clause J there's
a lot to J for now I'm going to simplify
it J is really our select list that's
where we're numerating variables
we want to do something with the third
parameter is the by clause which is
equivalent to sequels grouped by and
this last parameter C calling C for
teaming enables us to take some of the
core capabilities of data table and
chain them together and that is where we
can get our order buys and are having
clauses and things like that is this
helpful all right let's get into some
code to connect to the data table
library and expose it to our and what
we're gonna do is we're going to take
empty cards and we're gonna convert it
into a data table and call it DTM T cars
data table by the way unlike data Fram
that they're very similar
and data frame is a type of data table
as a type of data frame but it doesn't
have running so we'll use the parameter
keep row names set that to true and that
will take the data frame row names and
create a column out of it all right
filtering who said empty cars has 32
rows let's display only those cars that
have eight cylinders so we'll use the
first parameter the I filter out where
cylinders is equal to
next let's glare some more conditions on
top of that so it was 14 or so roads
let's bring that down to two and we'll
do that by adding on two more conditions
let's say where the weight is less than
four I'm guessing that's thousands of
pounds and and I would like you to pay
attention to the third filter which is a
light clause and we're saying there that
the row name is like or contains
abbreviation for Mercedes that's really
powerful
it's really powerful because we're
essentially the way I think of it is
we're creating an R vector and we're
passing that our vector into our I or
filter clause of data table and that
opens up a ton of possibilities to
create some really tight slick code
which we'll see as we go on more
filtering we want to see the first five
rows we can just index that one two five
which eliminates the need to take
something out of a data frame and top it
into an intermediary table and head it
now let's get some data out let's say we
want to get the the row names or cars we
can move from the I parameter over to
the J parameter take row names out and
take it out as a vector alternatively
data table can use this double square
bracket syntax get the same result but
apparently this is much much more
optimized also a vector output and let's
start getting data tables out so here
we're going to move away from an
individually enumerated column and start
using our lists very similar but what
we'll get here on the output is
data table we can start extending this
to add any number of columns we'd like
and grow our output data table now data
table like any package has many
different syntax which will give you the
same output and here we're going to
start getting into some of the shortcuts
that were built into data table and
hopefully this will demystify a bit of
what data table does and its syntax okay
floor slacks same result the first is
what we saw on the previous slide from
empty cars taking three columns out the
second is exactly the same with one
difference there's a shortcut inside of
david' table we can abbreviate list and
replace it with a dot same exact results
now if whatever reason we don't want to
use a list let's say we have a vector
we're passing it into a function we can
use that we can use a vector and in the
specify the vector and the second
parameter the J and in the last third
parameter use width equals false very
very useful if you're generalizing
functions with data tables
last also vector-based but instead of
explicitly enumerated a rope pardon me a
column we're going to use the column
numbers good
all right continuing with the select
clause all right
data table has a very cool feature that
will let you specify which columns you
choose to manipulate and that feature is
excessive the sabri VSD so SD is a token
and it's telling data table that
somewhere in this syntax there are
variables explicitly enumerated that you
should process on so in this particular
case it's going to say in the SD columns
start with row name go through and
cylinder then you can see that on the
output down there okay suppose you want
to make some code generic and run it on
many columns and you want to specify
what that column is in your code to
execute you can use this double dot
notation and what the double dot
notation is telling data table is the
column you're seeking to process is a
variable name look in the contents of
that variable name and execute your code
again very very powerful when you want
to make general-purpose functions
alright let's shift gears over to group
bys
again 32 rows in empty cars but we want
to group it and aggregate it up to in
this case cylinder and we want to apply
the mean function for miles per gallon
so we're going to use the third
parameter of the by to specify the
cylinder and add the mean function to
the J parameter in the middle and by the
way there's a cool thing that I haven't
shown here which is that by Clause you
can use vectors so if you want to
aggregate by multiple variables you can
just drop that in here to here what
we're doing is in the aggregate function
we're defining what we want the name of
the output column to be so here it was
v1 here on the output the column name is
mpg
okay there's something different about
this function and I'm going to ask you
what it is once I'm done explaining it
what I'm trying to do here is to apply
more and more of ARs functions that are
accessible to us inside the table data
table so here what we want to do let's
say we have a new data set we want to
start seeing on a broad basis what the
contents of that are but what data table
does really well is that lets us crunch
big data in a short amount of time so
here what we're saying is let's a
granade our data here by cylinder let's
get the mean but we want to apply that
mean not to one column but to many
columns and and we do that by using the
combination of the SD columns so that's
saying start on the left at
miles-per-gallon and end at carburetor
and everyone in between and use the L
apply the SD and the mean to apply that
broadly okay so that's what this code is
doing what's different about this code
pardon
yes exactly exactly this piece of data
table code has four parameters
everything that we've talked about up to
this point had three so most of the time
you're only going to have three
generally speaking but here would the SD
and the SD columns we have an extra
parameter
Chaney
the concept of chaining in the data
table world is to take basic blocks of
data table functions like that and keep
it pending them on to the end not to hit
people with tell us so what we're gonna
do here is we'll use the same example
that we had before will aggregate by
cylinder we'll apply the mean two miles
per gallon but then we'll take that
result and we'll say filter it where the
aggregate miles per gallon is above 16
so whereas before this return three rows
now it's returning to and it's great
because if you're working with really
large data there's no need to have an
intermediate data data fire did a frame
data table it's all handled for you
internally two data table same exact
concept with chaining and order by will
take the aggregate results and will sort
them ascending with the minus sign by
miles per gallon which has an inverse
correlation with cylinders
vectors by the way do you guys know what
movie this is from airplane okay do you
know the name of the character names in
this scene partner vector victors one
partner yes Carina Clarence
what's your clearance Clarence and Roger
Roger Roger all right
why vectors just first I just want to
touch a little bit on some of the
percent in manipulation with vectors and
I want to go into some of the power of
data table with vectors basic examples
vectors of 1 to 2 1 to 6 the third line
of code 1 to 2 percent in percent 1 to 6
what's that going to return a vector of
length 2 of true true because the 1 and
2 both exist in the 1 to 6 vector and if
we flip it around in the fourth line 1
to 6 percent 10 percent 1 to 2 will be a
return of vector of length 6
true true for fossils because the 1 and
the 2 are there but the 3 to 6 or not
you can see that on the bottom
taking that to the next step the the
vector for cylinders so we're saying for
the vector of 32 cylinders where are
they in the other vector of four to six
can we get on the bottom that true the
vector of 32 true fossils that concept
is really powerful because at a very
large scale you can do this type of
processing amongst disparate data tables
I had this one well let's go through the
code melts like so pulling it all
together we're dropping that vector
ebullience generated by the percent in
into the first the I parameter of data
tables you know what this is going to
give us is only the fours and sixes then
the next chain is going to say the first
five rows and then the order by is going
to sort those first five rows I've had
examples where clients just dumped a
crazy number of tables on me 400 brought
tables our IT guys crunched we don't
have any documentation good luck we're
all counting on you
and and interrogating those tables with
this syntax you can start to demystify
the relationships between those tables
you know if you have one table that's
got six keys I can test where those keys
exist and don't exist in other tables at
a very large scale very quickly
so this is a recap of the select from
where group by an order by and how they
interrelate between data table and
sequel select all right we have two more
sections I want to go through and syntax
and then we'll dive into some real-world
examples joins what I want to do is
create a a summary table by cylinders
and then join that back into empty cars
so that's what this data table syntax up
here does we're gonna third by clauses
by cylinder the J clause in the middle
it's a list that has four different
functions that are doing means and
standard deviations it produces the
table on the bottom now we want to join
that newly created table back into empty
cars first thing we're gonna do is use
the set key V function that all that's
going to do is gonna order our table by
the vector we pass in as the second
parameter then the third line is going
to do the join I'll talk a little bit
more about this but to me this is one of
the less intuitive parts of the syntax
and I'll explain why in a minute but but
the next the end result is the empty car
tables on the left and the newly created
variables on the right I generally don't
use this syntax it's more efficient but
I tend to gravitate towards the merge
syntax on the right for two reasons one
processing speeds not a bottleneck I
don't need that efficiency I'm not doing
joins us frequently and - there's
implied logic
between the inner left and right joins
in the data table syntax in the middle
the the permutation of the X&Y will tell
you if you're doing a left and a right
the keys that are being joined by are
enumerated elsewhere in the set key it
works super fast and if you need that
performance that's awesome
I tend to gravitate towards the merge
syntax which will do exactly the same
thing and which will explicitly
enumerate everything you need to know
about your joint its trade-offs not
right or wrong and this is all courtesy
our studio this page inspired by so to
sum up some of the key shortcuts you'll
find in data table a single dot tells us
that it's a list the double dot tells us
the variable the Select entity is a
variable X and Y is right outer join and
as a
putting this together it kind of struck
me that it's really data table is kind
of ahead of the curve on emojis so big
Rin clown and what we're leading into
here is updates and the data table
syntax for updates is : full colon equal
and there's a reason for that in the
sequel world
the syntax between select and update are
very very similar
the from in the where can stay the same
swap out for select and drop in and
update in the set same syntax there's an
elegance to that so the idea behind the
data table design well we have an equal
in our j clause we use it for column
names we use it for aggregations okay
let's add on a col and make it an update
in the rest of the pieces the eye and
the by stay the same it kind of makes
sense to me I think all right let's say
we want to add a new column and we want
the value to be one for every row which
I find useful if I want to do a count
I'll just sum up on this column so the
ways to do it but this works for me
layering on a little more functionality
suppose we want a new column to be the
manufacturer name which is the first
word in the row name column so we'll use
G sub will pick off the first word we
will assign that to the vector V dot
manufacturer and then we'll take that
vector and using the colon equal syntax
create the new column manufacturer and I
broke it apart just so it be hopefully a
little easier to get your head wrapped
around in in real life I would code that
all into one statement and continuing on
with the update suppose we wanted to
create a new indicator variable as a
potential independent variable in this
case what we'll do is we'll have an is
Mercedes indicator and we'll set it
equal to 1 under the condition and our
Ike laws that the manufacturer is equal
to mark there's two things I'd like you
to take away from this on the output
number one there's no assignment
statement in a dataframe world we would
have to create this new column and
assign it back into a new data frame
very efficient
it's the by reference processing versus
the be by value processing two on the
bottom there are seven rows where this
indicator will have a value of one what
happens to the other 25 you get your n/a
automatically you don't have to touch it
it's handled for you by data table then
you may choose to make that a zero you
may choose to process it as is it's
concise and
all right we're almost done with syntax
and we'll get into some some real-world
stuff here I just wanted to make you
aware of other functions available to
you from data table there's F read
there's F right for getting common
delimited data in and out very quickly
it has all sorts of parallel processing
features built-in read and save our DS
for writing data tables in and out set
names set column order or D caste melt
you can change your column name set the
order and you can melt and D cast your
table using data table and it's very
fast and it's very efficient that's all
I'll touch on for now okay covered that
all right get in there let's talk about
some real-world stuff with with data
table these are features that have been
layered on top of data table these are
real-world examples and these go
directly back to being handed 450 raw
ERP tables by the client CSV no
documentation no tech guy to talk about
decrypt these demystify them and good
luck we're all counting on you so I'm
gonna jump around here so the first
thing I did when I got this and it was
brand new to our by the way when I did
this I created this function called EDD
it's a very think of EDD enhanced data
dictionary as a variant of the summary
function but to me it it presents the
output and describes the variable row by
row in a very concise manner so if you
look at the bottom here along the bottom
I don't know you can read this so well
but each row represents one variable it
will tell me its best guess at datatype
how many are unique how many are na how
many are blank and fill rates for for
continuous variables it'll give me the
center or the mean and the percentile
spread for the categorical variables of
the factors it'll give me the top ten
values by frequency wrap it around a
function that will display it in a shiny
package which is kind of cool what I did
was I ran this 450 times one for each
table and they stacked all the output
together into one data table and in that
data table I can start making
connections between where the column
names similar where do they link are the
number of unique values the same I can
pass this into a generic function to
plot these out and in a glance I can
skim through these very very quickly it
really really helped me demystify a lot
of data quickly time series data I wind
up doing a lot of time series data in my
analysis and here what I'd like to point
out is for a pretty large time series
data set there's over 100 million rows
I'm able to filter and do whatever
functions I'd like so in this case I'm
doing the percentile so I've got that
set from 0 to 1 in increments of 0.1 and
doing the quantile on a lot of different
variables at levels of aggregation that
I want so in this case I'm aggravated by
two variables in the back
putting them in here one of the common
problems I find in either debugging
something as I'm getting to a master
data set or more importantly reflecting
accurate results back to clients is what
for me it's getting filters right it's
gonna bias your population in one way or
the other it's going to account for
business dynamics and to get clients to
embrace that I need to be transparent
about what those filters are and what I
find with this code here in this example
there's one filter but I have code that
has dozens of filters per table it's all
laid out cleanly and crisply and
whoever's going and combing through that
code has a quick path to knowing what
those filters are
yeah there's some scoring code that I
sanitized the variable names for but
what I wanted to articulate here is once
you have your model trained and you're
running it in a production basis you can
produce some code that I think is pretty
tight what's what's your dependent
variable coefficients intercept
variables and in this example taking
that and wrapping it up until logic
model so my my output is always going to
be between 0 & 1 this is another
function I wrote as I was navigating
those 450 tables I needed to know the
Venn diagram view of two different
variables where do they intersect where
do they appear in only one side or only
the other so the first two parameters of
this function are passing in vectors
from data tables second to parameters or
labels and then the output is telling me
what the Union intersection and left and
right sides of that Venn diagram are
so here's an example of burying inside
of your data table a plot call you know
really what I want to do is I'm starting
to visualize the data because they want
data table to crunch the data and I want
to hand off a summary set of data to
whatever graphing function is being used
so in this with this method we can build
the plot directly into our data table
this would produce however many
manufacturers there are so I think it's
20 so we'd get one in graph for each of
these another way to think of that and I
got this on Stack Overflow but I have
something similar this is a generic
function it's going to take as
parameters a data table the variable we
want to be the x-axis the variables we
want for the y-axis and and some metrics
I'm sorry the the Z is what we want to
facet by it's generic it's awesome so so
what I do here is they go back to my EDD
I know where my factor variables are I
know what my continuous variables are
and then they feed that into this so you
very quickly get through the
visualization of a really large group of
data what I'd love to do is to get this
plugged into trellis code but I haven't
had time to get that to work yet
okay let's shift gears we're gonna wind
down the code portion of this and talk
about something that might be a little
unexpected it might be a little
counterintuitive and it's something that
gets me very very excited all right I'm
in touch with my inner geek here it's a
server it's a server I built when I look
at this picture this is what I think
about
it's crazy fast it is so what you want
to know is it's got four CPUs a lot of
desk any two disks can fail I could pull
them out and the machine will still run
but most importantly it's got a terabyte
of RAM so I'm surprised that like lights
don't dim as this thing boots up this is
my team's day-to-day tool for getting
our job done and I cannot underestimate
how crazy fast it is and because it runs
out of memory because it runs out of
memory the physical mechanical side of
the of the server the disks which failed
most often they're not use much I'll
read in the big data set
I'll flush it out at the end of the day
so there's a copy on disk
it's crazy fast your phone typical phone
has inside of it eat cores in it CPU
this one has six thousand it's got it in
the form of a couple of GPUs here's what
I think is the most surprising thing
about this it's got an out-of-pocket
cost of $21,000
it's it's really high quality hardware
and it's really not that expensive now
you have to want to tinker you have to
enjoy that it's not a perfect solution
we were busy building Basile models the
regulator's were coming in at the client
site and the next day and a half and it
started throwing out some errors and
apparently there's a history of Samsung
solid state disks melting down so but I
think we have the right model wrapped
around it because all of the code sweeps
out to the cloud all of the original
data sets that we work with that were
provisioned to us are on the cloud and
then I need to rebuild my master data
set at this large scale I can do it in
hours you know part of one of the
platforms I've built out was for a big
bank
it had trillions of transactions
hundreds of terabytes of data and it is
in use by 2000 modelers I would use this
in a heartbeat over that this is such an
awesome environment to work with and
it's it's the memory it's our and it's
data table that that's the essence of
this
most don't that is absolutely right I I
put that here for a reason and I'll come
that's a good point I will come to that
thank you that is the perfect lead-in to
this so one of the things I worked on
was a transit transition migration
matrixes some legacy code when they were
first written however many years ago
they would run in two to three hours and
really what you want to know is there's
a lot of matrix math on this a lot over
time the the portfolio of loans grow
more functions were thrown into the code
and eventually it took a day and a half
or so to run so we were asked to take a
look at it and to see what we could do
first thing we did was we rewrote the
code in our data table and we got some
crazy good performance numbers in the 1
million row range what was running in
two and a half days is running at six
seconds but we had this idea that
instead of looking at this as a report
that you run daily or weekly or monthly
and look at what if it was really a
simulation tool and you can do all sorts
of what-if analysis on it so what we
wanted to test our hypothesis was to do
this on a GPU this is a four years ago
and at that time the only way we can get
into the low-level libraries to
manipulate the GPU was through C or
Python
all right so fine till we rewrote the
code into Python the performance numbers
were quite good but not nearly as good
and my hypothesis I don't know for
certain my hypothesis is that was due to
two data table same hardware but the R
was really much faster
but then we loaded the data set onto the
GPO
and we manipulated it only on the GPO
you know and we brought that down
significantly from from six seconds to
sub-second and it scales up very nicely
in some sort of kind of linear way
that's one thing the other thing and
this has nothing to do with data table
sorry it's just kind of fun it's just a
computer vision algorithm
it runs on a tablet I have and it's 95
percent act it identifies retail
products it's really using pixel data
right now it's changed train for baby
products and it's 95 percent accurate
that's just something else I'm tinkering
with that's it
[Applause]
pardon I'm sorry which syntax they okay
yeah yeah yes
[Music]
interesting is it using the our
libraries I'm with deep fire syntax is
that the concept that's a very cool
concept I'm not honest my first exposure
to deep fire to be honest was at JD's
talk a few months ago this works really
really well for me and I don't have a
good answer for you it's the syntax
coming through the learning curve is
real but it's fast it's super fast
I haven't priced it my hunch is it'll be
within the same ball park plus or minus
a couple thousand dollars and you'll
probably get a much much faster GPU the
we do use cloud we use cloud at a
dramatically smaller scale because we're
putting two things out there we're
putting all of our code and analysis and
we're putting the data that's provision
to us and that's our in case something
happens we can scale up the cloud and
run with it I started looking at it I
don't know that the numbers I put
together or write on spot because I'm to
be honest not super fluent in the cloud
but the numbers I saw in the spot market
how did it something like forty thousand
dollars a year so to answer your
question would I do this again for me in
a heartbeat because it's that crazy fast
and I have the comfort that the clouds
there if I need it
when I was you know when I was doing
that it was not available to us and that
just came out in the our benchmarks that
or these new set of benchmarks came out
two months ago but I am very keen and
looking at that there there's some nice
features that can make that work but if
you look at the benchmarks there are
certain benchmarks that didn't run on
that Python are because it's not yet
implemented there so my view on it is
it's a good first step and it's not
really big yet
this is all the machine I made there's
no this is all three of these are in the
machine I made no typos the first column
is first two columns are without the GPO
so 32 cores only ours performance with
data table pythons performance this
column here we took the data set and we
moved it onto the GPU the GPU has 6000
cores it has I believe 8 gigs of memory
and the data and the processing in this
scenario occur completely within the
scope of the GPU and the GPU is awesome
at anything connected with dot products
or sorting because those are two
problems that lend themselves very very
nicely to parallelization and and that's
what's inside of much of the deep
learning and the computer vision stuff
you see out there they're based on GPUs
and products like GPUs
I am NOT very familiar with the per
package yes yes I do and the way to do
that is to within the je clause is to
put your code within squiggly brackets
and you can embed our code within that
je function using that method a lot of
though I'm not familiar of SHINee now
but basically the idea is you start and
end with the squiggly brackets and you
drop in our code with that so my hunch
is that would work but I can't say that
I've done it with a per package I've
done it with other functions
so the question is do I think there will
be an ecosystem around data table
similar to the ecosystem around deep
liar the design decision that went into
data table is to expose our functions
within data table so I think implicitly
that ecosystem exists
I mean it's I'm writing a matching
engine now and it's awesome to be able
to use a lot of the string distance
libraries that are accessible to me and
invoke that from within a data table I
guess you could look at that through the
lens of an ecosystem but it would be the
broader our ecosystem it's probably an
ecosystem that's not marketed as an
ecosystem
it was pandas is exactly pandas it was
there was some numpy numpy in there too
there's some of the dot product it's you
can distill this code down into some
algebra and dot products that's the
essence of it and numpy is very good at
those dot products
[Applause]